l'arbre source de vie on pourrait croire
à un slogan publicitaire pourtant c'est
une vérité que l'homme a trop souvent
oublié ce sont des totems ce sont des
marqueurs de notre civilisation de notre
paysage urbain des témoins vivants on
doit les respecter comme tout être
vivant on doit les
respecter
entre ciel et terre ce trait d'union
indispensable est aussi un témoin de
l'histoire des hommes comme cesif dont
le bois servait à fabriquer les Arces
des archers anglais durant la guerre de
100 ans ou encore ce tuilipier
originaire d'Amérique du Nord de plus de
27 m de haut il fleuri en mai juin des
fleurs en forme de tulipe qui sont des
fleurs hermaphrodite d'ailleurs très
discrètes parce qu'elles sont jaunes
vert et se confondent dans le dans le
feuillage les forêts représentent plus
de 8200 hectares sur le territoire où
ces arbres remarquables ont été recensés
au-delà de leur espèce particulière
certains enferment des histoires sur
leurs origines comme ce chîn vert très
présent dans le bassin méditerranéen qui
ne perd jamais ses feuilles et se
renouvelle constamment c'est l'arbre de
Zeus dans le temple de d'odonne c'est
l'arbre d'Hercule à de Jupiter pardon à
Rome c'est l'arbre du dieu Thor
également et dans la Bible là voilà on
rejoint la Bible c'est un arbre très
important pour la Bible et ça fait
partie également c'est un des arbres
d'Allah donc c'est vraiment l'arbre
ecuménique la France représente 13 % de
la surface boisée de l'Union européenne
elle est le 3è pays d'Europe pour sa
surface forestière après la Suède et la
Finlande